bien alors maintenant on va faire une
interview nulle nulle on bouge
[Musique]
pas bon vous vous arbitrez Jean gu
Stéphane d'accord
d'ord la mauvaise idée que la mauvaise
idée maintenant vous m'avez collé ça
dans le cigar vous allez vous appeler
je- Stéphan pour toute la vie ça marche
ok ah
[Musique]
non suis dans la mer et je vous
bien alors Roger vous êtes prêt
interview nulle est-ce que vous
préfériez votre père ou votre mère ma
mère ah ouais vous le dites carrément
vous j'adorais mon père mais moi je
préférais ma mère ah c'est bien un petit
dAlger il aime bien sa maman dans le sud
c'est un peu comme ça he non oui je
pense c'est très su ça oui je pense euh
vous préfériez Staline ou Hitler Staline
Staline pourquoi parce qu'il a tué plus
de gens d'abord je ne crois pas qu'il
ait tué plus de gens là je vais perdre
un peu mon sens de l'humour d' je trouve
je trouve que c'est monstrueux Staline
tant qu'on veut et allons-y c'est c'est
l'homme qui a dévoyé l'un des plus beaux
idéals qui est l'idéal communiste mais
maintenant je sais que c'est la mode de
de de comparer les communistes et les
nazis et moi c'est pas mon sentiment
voilà d'accord oui c'est vrai qu'on
compare on dit il y a eu deux
totalitarismes au 20e siècle il y a eu
l'hitlérisme et le stalinisme c'est vrai
qu'on a on les compare vous pensez que
c'est pas comparable non non non parce
que je me suis fait accrocher une fois
dans une émission on m'a dit comment
osez-vous dire que vous êtes communiste
dit d'abord ne me parlez pas sur son là
et pourquoi pas nazi je dis mais moi je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que je
peux vous résumer l'idéal communiste
l'idéal communiste c'est justice et
partage maintenant vous définissez-moi
l'idéal nazi définitivement l'idéal nazi
et voyons si ça se confond c'est vrai
qu'au début l'idée communiste était une
plus belle idée que que l'idée nationale
socialiste ah oui je trouve force de le
reconnaître c'est vrai alors est-ce que
vous préféreriez faire l'amour avec une
fille très laide ou un mec très beau une
fille très laide
ah il a un CORG quand même c'est
vraiment matchoman euh est-ce que vous
avez plus de circonst vous donnez plus
de circonstances atténuantes à à à des
vieux qui se tapent des jeunes ou à des
jeunes qui tapent sur des
vieux plutôt des jeunes qui se tapent
des vieux parce que je trouve c'est un
signe de générosité extraordinaire ouais
non j'avais dit des jeunes qui tapent
sur des vieux qui tapent sur des
viux par que je sais bien non non mais
j'ai compris dans votre bouquin dans le
bouquin de Roger Dentel effectivement
Aurélie ve taper le de 70 ans plutôt des
vieux qui tapent sur des jeunes Ahou
d'accord parce que son ils ont fini leur
vie des T qu biener vous qui êtes un
vous qui êtes un
spécialiste le mot le plus con en amour
c'est merci encore oui
oui le plus con le plus con c'est c'est
oui oui oui oui vous avez compris dire
oui alors la bombe atomique arrive dans
5 minutes vous faites quoi
ben je je je m'agenouille et je prie
ouais 5 minutes qu'est-ce que je peux
faire toute façon tu as pas le temps d'y
aller làamis ça enfleur en même temps
tout seul alors ouais ou alors tout seul
oui votre partenaire n'est pas très
excité vous lui demandez comment il
s'appelle vous lui faites un truc
spécial
vous vous cassez en claquant la
porte je crois que je pars sans claquer
la porte bien élevé non parce que
d'abord ça ne change rien et on se
diminue en éant violent ouais vous
croyez pas au truc j'urais pas dit ça il
y a 20 ans ou 30 ans il y a 20 ans vous
ariez dit quoi le truc spécial
ouioui bien si vous étiez mort vous vous
voudriez être incarné en quoi attention
hein en Édouard
Baladur en giscardestin ou en pierre
Messmer en pierre Mesmer en pierre
Mesmer oui parce que ça étéit bon j'ai
pas ces ID des politiques mais c'est un
héros il a une belle gueule il est il a
il a parlé net et puis il a pendant la
guerre il a été trs très bien conduit on
vous applaud c'est une très bonne très
bonne interview
nul c'est une intervie nul qui n'était
pas nul